é docente na área do desporto a mais de
mim
nos aparta carreira acadêmica traz no
currículo a autoria do livro para
crianças ea criação de uma nova
modalidade esportiva é tripla rui matos
falava série passam de 700 pessoas 1.400
olhos 1.400 ouvidos à espera que eu diga
alguma coisa de bola à equipa
olha olá meu nome é remadas uma
decoração de empresas de fora que muitos
livros são a minha filha está algures no
loucão minha mulher está ao lado na voz
mas sei que estão a dizer que eu não
estou invertido
tudo com calma não estão invertidos
mas tudo divertido mas não estou
convertido sendo convertida convergência
e divertida de emergência
eu gosto de gente não gosta convergência
e é por isso que entrei pra falar
aproveitando aquela dica da pouco mas
não entrei falar do forma entrei falar
com esse trechinho está aqui conseguem
certamente mais ou menos verde tinha
este bichinho por dois motivos 1 é que
eu não sou mais velhos ou menos um dos
menos rio comunicador daqui do tempo e
portanto ter um dinossauro comigo dá um
certo conforto eu vou colocar um carro
longe de mim vou colocar aqui sobre o t
centenas já vou também dizer um pouco
mais sobre isto e por outro lado permite
também que diminua a opção é força área
não só da matemática mas gosto muito e
essa força que ainda no ar
dividindo por mim ela está sempre a
minha atenção e vão ter um olho no burro
em um olho azul ou no charlie chaplin o
tom já não é o padrão é outro
bom eu vou falar sobre a modalidade
esportiva que eu criei se chama tripé
ela chama de tripé lula pé de nós com
cabeça não sei não sou velho martins
mas enfim não tem problema nenhum rui
matos também r é nova para mim
quem também não estava presente essas
coisas acontecem
vamos pra que ela apareça pode ser dava
tanta gente ter a minha apresentação é
mesmo bom vamos ver se é possível
solicitar um compasso de espera ela
parece já vai em 2005 economia não pára
não faço não faz muito sentido
quem é que já ouvi falar do braço
não quero levantar o vasco não vem
ninguém não é aliás essa também é uma
forma mais tranquila está atraindo muita
gente pode baixar a atenção alguns
quando nós falamos para 10 pessoas nós
temos forma para cada uma delas e para
todas as suas formas para ninguém para
ter uma tranquilidade tremenda do fato
agora sim mas este senhor já que está
porque enfim já está aí muito bem
conhece e se tinha algum lado não
conhecem ninguém conhece
eu não saí não tive oportunidade com
festas de ir ver se esse foi um grande
esportista teve fotos porto mas o senhor
tem algum interesse na minha aplicação
para não dizer muito o total interesse
não se consegue reparar mas eu vou
ajudar consegue ver o que está ali a
hipótese de fugir mas não não é pode
surgir e e agora o nome da senhora já
sabem já tinha esse mesmo é isso mesmo
antónio pinho carvalho falou antônio mas
eu sei que a resposta completa antônio
mello pinho carvalho ser curioso que o
estado de cada ser ouvidas nos autos
sendo gallup né
talvez cause mas não de costas de
lançá-los e de conseguir põe também que
essa figura não me sai da cabeça está
sempre também em cima do t é o
tiranossauro rex
mais conhecido por rex e dos amigos
bom esse bichinho é é um bicho terrível
né calcula se que fosse de 70 santa mãe
as pessoas falam tanta coisa mas nunca
viram mas acredita se que este bicho tá
como nos filmes do parque e 70 que o
bicho era mesmo mal
também agora já se diz que eu só comigo
pois visitarem morte não era assim tão
bem mas enfim era um carnívoro era era
pequenino não era ela que ele não tinha
esse tamanho todo para o espaço de 8 50
se quisermos ver assim pesava mais ou
menos 2 mil fãs médios o que quer que
seja e tenha a altura de três pessoas e
63 pessoas e mãe era um bicho de normas
eram desprezados e era um bicho de algum
modo embora houvesse agressões é um
bicho de algum modo lentos
claro que isto é tudo relativo se
compararmos com este bicho era realmente
eram realmente lembra não é esse bicho
cerca de 120 quilômetros por hora
isso tudo isso que vem agora as notícias
tanto agora já desporto finalmente não é
só o bicho de dinossauros 45 km da hora
alguns dinossauros há 15 anos 60
quilômetros por hora mas a minha parte
do zero mesmo relativamente doente e
então que esteve com conversa e que
esteja com o sport vai ter alguma coisa
redondinha uma e eventualmente poderia
ser um buraco num campo de golfe né
falta relva e espaços verdes não deve
ser propriamente um buraco do flamengo
sabe o que é estar na sua toca e não é o
que estou a fazer uma conversa não é os
pits conversarmos muito fácil mas é o
que é isso
terra uma cratera mas que a cratera
teria esse direito é daquelas conversas
do catar era de chicxulub tem que olhar
porque não é fácil municipal do rio
catar no méxico
segundo algumas teorias trás equipes o
fim desses mimosas animais
ainda bem para nós já vou explicar
porque em prol do desporto
a minha teoria que os dinossauros trouxe
morte de vilson sacrificaram estava
maneira pelo desporto porque os
dinossauros continuar assim e não via
desporto e não haveria certamente tripé
lula
é este senhor top pensar nisso estou
senhor talvez também não tenha pensado
nisso este senhor pensou não acredito
nisto e quem são estes senhores estão
aqui para ainda que o de maio
este senhor é é a água não deu
james naismith o inventor do basquetebol
em 1891 e da ponta e aí tá é william
monaghan o inventor do voleibol 4 895
curiosamente os dois trabalharam no
mesmo sítio dos estados unidos da
américa um colégio você já ouviu falar
do msn já a música te dão na ceia do
senhor e então me odone rert i am
pepe não há espanto se ainda o lay e em
qualquer coisa assim
o assunto é bom mas eu lembrei me disto
lembrei me disto e trazer isto porque eu
gosto muito e nos autos mas só o tempo
que ficaram para nós podemos inventar o
desporto é um bicho desses bichos
este é o meu é o braquiossauro
braquiossauro porque é um salto
significativo garante não ser lagartos a
letra são rápidas mas ainda assim é um
lagarto braço do norte braço porque tem
os membros anteriores pelas portarias
ela na verdade nenhum é visto no mesmo
desaparecer se não haveria desporto para
bichos com o corpo muito grande
ops comandados por uma cabeça muito
pequena desta forma nós estamos na parte
das formas não podia resultar forma
nenhuma pensar que isso não era possível
e portanto fora como é que esse serviço
é uma vez cunha nesta posição para us 32
pés no chão os dois pés no ar antes um
pé no chão
todos os braços na frente na tabela
temos que receber a bola com as mãos e
se passar o pente que ela caia porque eu
já que todos os bares fazem toda a gente
faz esse gesto
os dinossauros não podia fazer então
estava na altura de inverter isto e como
é que se começou a inverter isto começou
a se inverter da seguinte forma graças a
estes bichinhos está aqui quem tem a ver
com isso e com outros agora bom sabor da
gente conhece né que costuma dizer
rapidamente podemos afirmar que eles mas
nem mesmo o bom e velho rock já chega e
agora os dois que ficou em comum estes
dois poderiam dizer se falassem que ela
fizesse não é duro dizer mas na história
o uso de óleos e agora história e agora
aqui purga por vitórias é o nome
interpor um bicho não é por vitórias
este bichinho viveu por dizer há cerca
de 65 milhões de anos diz alguma coisa
quando tem um espírito
foi quando os dinossauros se fixaram foi
contemporâneo por pouco tempo dos
dinossauros mas o fato de nós termos a
partida permitiu e outra classe de bicho
passassem a dominar a terra não os
répteis como os dinossauros até então
mas livros
este foi o primeiro pensa sim cientistas
não ligou o primeiro primata do qual nós
nos víamos não parece um macaco mas tem
uma dentição macaco com os primatas
então extra sido o primeiro a ir para em
que agora sim um corpo
já contei nem por que não com a cabeça
um carinho maior e é por esta alteração
vamos poder sobreviver melhor eu
concordo que qualquer do meteorito ou de
lixo tratamento de queimados e depois a
poeira que se levanta o fez com que não
fosse possível haver falta sim saber de
tais débitos morreu no dia essa hipótese
morreram os dinossauros herbívoros assim
os carnívoros é de 107 verão porque come
um pouco me um pouco os dinossauros que
muito há muito tempo atrás passou cura
que o dinão só uso o r comia o é come
até ter morrido depois no chão e comer
e então então uns anos mais tarde né há
dois milhões de anos surgiu este outro
animal jamais pacífico nos este animal é
que o italiano como água luz e parem
vocês viram a casa das patas e as mãos
daquilo braquiossauro não é conseguir
libertar naquelas partes não conseguiu
sair do chão eu precisava delas para se
mover
essa é a grande vantagem a partir do
amor a deus é que nós ficamos com as
mãos livres estudaram e certamente na
escola e portanto estão a estudar em
alguns com as mãos livres é possível
também libertar o cérebro e é possível
pensar em outra forma e é possível
começar a manipular objetos como por
exemplo que ambos portanto pode-se dizer
na verdade que sou o verdadeiro primeiro
livro aos livros e tendas nos livros
obrigatória tendo é as mãos livres
como passou a ter isso fez com que eu
disse sobre as alterações mais profundas
e então para que grandes mudanças forma
esta é agora são corpos relativamente
pequenos cabeças faturamento grandes
plataformas do tiranossauro rex o
director do tec
então eu tenho uma cabeça de era grande
o metro e vinte anos o corpo era 314
portanto a porcentagem não chegava a 10
em nossa percentagem possa crescer 12%
neste exemplo está aqui e estão aí mas
neste ps é o dobro do valor representa
25% do seu tamanho tanto
alguém tem dúvidas que são estes erros
mas no mundo que tem feito sob seu
comando é grande e coorpin
bom eu não direi que tem uma cabeça
muito grande mas ainda assim tenho mais
ou menos do tamanho que vocês têm e
portanto não há nada que você possa
parar só alguns velhos do hotel é que
podem tentar parar as nossas idéias nós
temos que ser fortes a acreditar que é
possível salvar as novidades lanche
acreditar nisso não deixar que nos
querem as nossas ideias que exponham
barreiras que nos puseram nosso bar pra
outro lado temos que tirar e temos que
nos rodear de pessoas que acreditem
também é que nós fazemos não é um
exemplo algumas pessoas algumas não se
conhecem em acreditar também que o temos
feito e eu quero aproveitar aquilo que
ele também quer a nossa corda aperta o
autor afirma jeff ray
é quase o mesmo terminar
se funcionasse era ótimo só para ficarem
com medo e não vamos parar o jogo de
tripla esse bichinho falar em bicho não
é bom nem vossa casa vão juntos busquem
vão procurar a tabela 63 páginas são
sobre tela provavelmente como disse a
ganhar largar e vi a mensagem agora
mesmo os mais novos não deixem que vos
obstruam o vosso caminho quando vos
quiserem fazer isso você respondam
apurar a responder à altura
não é por saber que os pés muitas vezes
as melhores respostas vêm de uma altura
muito baixinha por vezes nós baixamos e
respondemos à altura alguns senhores que
acredito que nós temos que ser todos
assim então vamos esconder esses
senhores 10 estabelece a obrigação